It's passing any gas at all after a meal, or ever a sign of leaky gut. How much gas is too much?
Um, no, I wouldn't say that having gas is a sign of leaky gut.
If you never pass gas, I would say, that's probably not normal. It's normal for you to have some
level of fermentation of food in your cup, creating gas that you'll have to have. So it's never
normal to not have gas. How much gas is too much? Well, yeah, I wouldn't say it's a sign of leaky gut,
but if you have excess gas, like, oh my gosh, I have so much gas, I don't know what's wrong with me,
it's just, it's, this is way more than normal for me, would be a sign of maldigestion.
So that can also accompany leaky gut, but it wouldn't be a sign of leaky gut itself.
Valdigestion is because food isn't being properly digest. Usually it's a deficiency in a
vitrophoric acid and an insufficiency in pancreatic enzymes, so you're not properly digesting
your foods and you're getting, you know, excess fermentation of your foods and you're getting
excess gas production. So the treatment, quote unquote, for that would be to increase HCl
with each meal and pancreatic enzymes with your meals to help you break down your food. That's
basically what, like, products like beetle, you know, that are, they're just digestive enzymes. So
taking digestive enzymes and HCl would be the treatment. You feel like you have excess gas.
Also making sure you're having bowel movements. Some people have very slow digestive tracks,
they're not having bowel movements, and their intestinal transit time is very slow. You want to make
sure that you support that as well. Go back to the seven phases of detoxification course
to help you with this question, too.